all right well my name is Spencer and
to talk I'm going to talk to you about
using immutable data structures in C
sharp and dotnet in general also
applicable how many vb.net developers in
here okay how many people just don't
want to admit it alright so talk about
real quick objective you double it which
is just an adjective to describe
something that cannot change right and
immutability really in our world in the
world of programming just refers to a
data structure of some kind that once
it's in stanch eiated and put in memory
it can't be changed at all or put in
something permanent storage if it's
immutable cannot change the properties
can't change right and I think it's
really beautiful it's really impacted my
programming career for the better at
least thinking about it not only on the
dotnet you know it's c-sharp level but
also thinking about architecture which
I'll talk about a little later and I
think that it's really important to talk
about if you're gonna do an immutable
talk you at least have to mention
functional programming right and
functional programming is one of those
things that I don't do on a day-to-day
basis my main language is dotnet or
sorry c-sharp occasional vb.net which
I'm proud of I'm proud of it even if the
people who chose it weren't and really
functional programming is for me has
been a thought exercise and really kind
of introspecting about how I develop
software and how I can develop software
better right because in an imperative
language like C sharp they the languages
themselves have different priorities and
different principles about how they
operate functional programming doesn't
doesn't necessarily like null it has a
very mutability is usually on by default
and it has a functional first kind of
mindset with data structures with a very
strong type system which I'm not gonna
get into the specifics of course we're
cheered us focus on immutability and I
think that really you can do an entire
talk in a day a very good talk on just
immutability in an hour anyways and
still touch on those other things and in
the way they inspire me so let's talk
about f sharp for a little bit so this
is a little bit of F sharp how many F
sharp developers in the room okay all
right one in the front row and this is
the guy that's going to be challenging
me
time like I don't know why you do that
but so this is a little F sharp for you
this is what's referred to as a record
type so record types have special
properties and that they boiled down to
essentially c-sharp classes or classes
in net and have a few a couple of
properties about them which is that they
are you have structural equality on by
default which means they're not compared
by reference they're compared by the
values of the properties and this thing
is immutable once you declare an
instance of it you can't change it
really that's and so that's a really
important concept for the for f-sharp in
general it's one of the things that it
kind of embraces you can actually make a
property on here mutable by putting in a
key word right here in front of a count
number called mutable but I think that
that really illustrates one of the
priorities and differences that f-sharp
has over C sharp F sharp really
prioritizes and really pushes you
towards immutability making mutability
an opt-in thing whereas c-sharp really
pushes you towards mutability as a first
class as a first class thing right and
really asks you to opt into mutability
right with extra code so quick question
how do you know if somebody is a
functional programmer that's easy it's
like somebody who does CrossFit if they
if they they're functional programmer
they'll let you know they won't shut up
about it and it's really important to
understand that c-sharp is something
that is Bill I've built a career on
c-sharp I loved c-sharp I think it's a
great language I can take functional
paradigms and principles from other
languages or at least other ways of
programming and apply them to c-sharp
but at its core I cannot change dot I
cannot change the CLR right the CLR was
built in an imperative style right I
can't change c-sharp that's not that's
not possible but what I can change maybe
is your mind and I gotta warn you that
there's a lot of bad immutability jokes
in this slide deck which just goes to
show you show you that some things
really do never change I want to
illustrate a me the idea of immutability
with an example that I think we can kind
of all understand how many people know
who Scott Hanselman is fair amount of
you that's a fairy that does it
easy one right so it Scott Hanselman if
you ever fall if you follow him on
Twitter about once a month or once every
week I don't know frequently it seems he
often complains about Twitter's lack of
an edit button inside of tweets and I
look at that and I say okay that's
that's kind of a thing but like typos
are on you is it really that hard to
delete a tweet but it really goes a
little bit deeper than that and let's
use our friend elan as an example so
this is a real elan tweet tweet where he
says defeating traffic is the ultimate
boss battle it's kind of funny it's kind
of quirky it's elan being elan whatever
so you look at that and if you're a
twitter user you might go ahead and give
that an rtii you might give that a
retweet and put that publish that to
your feet and say yes I agree with this
so then one day Twitter goes ahead and
publishes an edit button and suddenly
this innocuous tweet about defeating
boss battle or defeating traffic turns
into something like this okay that's a
kind of an American joke right so I'll
make it a little bit more topical for
you and I really and this really goes
back to a quote that John Carmack said
which is the large part of the flaws of
software development are due to
programmers not fully understanding the
state of the the state of execution of
that program and I think really
understand understanding and embracing
this is one of the first steps to really
kind of thinking about immutability in
your day to day programming lives when
you have something like an edit button
on Twitter you have to have you have to
ask all of these questions well if I
allow somebody to edit that tweet
let's may do I time box it within like
maybe the first 60 seconds what if
somebody's liked that tweet or what if
somebody's retweeted it published it to
their own feed for other people to
consume do I change am I able to change
the idea of the tweet suddenly you have
to think about all of these different
things that allow you to mutate that
tweet right now they're immutable died
up by default and that's a good thing
because you don't have to think about
any of that if you're on Twitter and
you're you and if you're a twitter user
or if your Twitter themselves and you're
and believe me people ask for the edit
button all the time but your when your
Twitter you have to think about things
like this with no edit button you don't
have to worry about people changing the
intent of the tweet it's immutable it
to change and therefore because it can't
change the idea can't change and you
don't have to consider all of this other
gobbledygook somebody pointed out when I
was talking about this concept is that
while also this will help simplify
Twitter's architecture because suddenly
they're not having to push edits from
edits now go straight from your phone or
straight from the Twitter servers up to
your phone or whatever device you're
using Twitter on which I thought was a
good point right I mean not that
Twitter's not good they have a great
architecture you can see as people like
your tweet you can see the little
numbers increment yay but if you're if
you're if you're a NASA and organization
where things like this have to be taken
into account suddenly you have to change
your architecture so I thought that was
a really interesting point I thought
worth mentioning here's another example
a little more closer to our world so we
have here an innocuous method and when
new dotnet developers kind of start to
you know they get past array and they
start to understand the power of lists
a lot of times I see do develop new
developers do dot to list all the things
right and it's it's a pretty easy habit
to get into it really doesn't really
hurt very often but then you look at
this method and me as I am looking at
this method I'm like well normally if I
create a method I with a list that takes
in a list I suddenly have to ask to my
ID like I'm usually usually intending to
mutate that list and when you present
somebody something like a method like
this where you're giving them a list
which a list has add removed methods
right suddenly am I supposed to under am
I supposed to expect that this method
whatever it does is supposed to be able
to add to this list is it supposed to be
able to remove from it is it supposed to
be why am I getting a list versus an
ienumerable which is just a forward only
read right so those kinds of questions
come have to come into account and maybe
I'm overthinking it a little bit but
there are plenty of instances in the.net
framework where the mutation recursion
is a great example of where you take a
list and you're building up a bit of
data or you're building up data and
possibly recursing over some other data
structure in order to build that data up
you might pass in a list intending for
that list to grow and mutate right and
this is really a function of just like
thinking now I have to think about all
the different states of mice that my
software is operating in right that goes
to the back to the John Carmack
now I have to interpret this method I
have to look at that and I have to think
well okay now I have to really do a lot
of thinking so there's a guy keval and
Henny did a who did this this slide
comes straight from a talk that he did a
couple of years ago that actually
inspired this talk and he talked about
this thing this this quad this uh this
graph and he talks about the the the the
quadrant at the top right he calls it
the synchronization quadrant which says
that if you have data that is shared
amongst multiple things right threads or
possibly just consumers in general and
that data is mutable when that mutate
when that data is mutated and consumed
when that data is mutated the suddenly
all of the other threads have to be
aware of that someway there has to be
some kind of synchronization process
that gets them that gets that memory
space all the way to the other threads
to consuming it right and this is really
an important thing when you're talking
about something like data that you when
you when you're processing a large
amount of data and you want to make a
guarantee you want to expectation that
that data is not going to change that
greatly simplifies the amount of
thinking and amount of architecture that
you have to have and this goes back to
Moore's Law right Moore's law I think is
important to bring up because a long
time ago
wellbut why I don't know a long time ago
20 years ago or so Intel and AMD and
other chip makers were locked in what
was called the gigahertz race where they
were just trying to make Giga processors
with the highest gigahertz they were
trying to make them faster and faster
right and eventually you know they they
hit a ceiling right they tried to make
what was essentially a super processor
the thing looks familiar
anyways when you're talking when when
you when you when you hit a physical
limit right like you are with the
gigahertz race and you suddenly can't
make process individual processors
faster suddenly you're having to
distribute workloads distributed
computing is something that we talk
about a lot right or at least we're
talking about it more as we've sort of
reached that limit and as a and as of
course the data need the needs for our
programs have risen so thus being able
to process data amongst multiple
assessors that amongst multiple
processors in a way that makes it that
ensures that you don't change that data
right if you're able to operate in an
assumption and you operate under the
assumption that the data is not going to
change suddenly you're Simplot your
architecture simplifies and you can make
you could often gain more performance by
making sure my not having to have any
synchronization process so let's talk
about the history of immutability and
dotnet I there's there is a little bit
of immutability just even baked into the
1.0 release right so we've all had this
right of passage as dotnet developers
where we've declared a string and then
we call dot replace on it and we
expected this question mark to turn into
that exclamation point and then you
wrote it to the console and suddenly are
disappointed and wondering why the heck
it just says replaceable as opposed to
replaceable everybody's had this right
of passage
eventually you come to the realization
that actually string dot replace returns
a new string instance of a string is
immutable if you change it a new
instance of a string is created
date/time operates in a very in a very
similar way right in order if if you
declare something that wraps date/time
dot now you're getting a new instance of
that and if you call add hours on it
you're not mutating the original
instance of that date/time you're
actually creating a new instance so
immutability in certain structures has
been a thing in dotnet for a little
while and this is how immutable classes
used to look right where we have a
read-only field and we just had a
property without a getter or without a
setter and then we just declared you
know public person and then just pass in
the first name right we don't need to go
over this this is old this is old stuff
and most of the time unless we're
looking at old code we probably don't
have to see this anymore certainly we
don't write it and then eventually we
got these auto properties where we could
also declare the accessibility modifier
on that auto property and this is pretty
close this was closed for a while but it
didn't quite hit the mark because
technically speaking the first name and
last name were still mutable till
c-sharp six came along and ah we got
these getter properties that can only be
set from the constructor that looks much
better
worth mentioning as well that c-sharp
7.2 and eight introduced well
sharp 7.2 introduced a read-only struct
which is a struct that is guaranteed to
be a read-only thing if you were this is
becomes important in high performance at
c-sharp applications the system texts
JSON API for example does declare
immutable or read-only structs to pass
certain data structures down in certain
instances where you're having to do
something special in system text jason
and they do that for performance one of
the reasons that library was rewritten
from newton written from the ground up
was because it was much more performant
than Newton soft up Jason
bottom line is is that this is how if I
declare a mutable data if I declare
mutable classes this is how I declare
them right it's very simple string first
name string last name and then just
close the setters delete them like
delete key click click it's all done I
understand that I think that there is a
proposal out there to put like an
accessibility modifier like right here
and just declare them and then you don't
even have to have this or something like
that I don't know if that's out I don't
know if that proposal exists but that's
what they do in typescript I think
there's a proposal out there but for now
this is what we got and it's pretty good
I think it's fine link is another
example of something that has embraced
immutability kind of from the beginning
and anonymous types one of the best
decisions that dotted that Microsoft
made was making anonymous types the way
they made them we've all seen them if
we've called if we've had some kind of
list and we wanted to select certain
data from that list and we didn't want
to create a whole new type for it we
just said yeah forget it you know we'll
just do we'll just create a new
anonymous type and just wrap a new
object and that's really useful
especially when you're doing grouping
operations and you don't want to have to
declare type for all these different
things and the cool thing about
anonymous types is that they are not
only immutable you can't change their
data they also embrace structural
equality by default unless you're using
vb.net for gal I do not understand why
they made that design decision that's
outside the scope of this talk what can
I say I think it's they do a lot of
weird stuff in VB bottom line is is that
once you put this into memory you can't
touch it you can't change that data once
it's there so immutability again link
embracing it embracing immutability by
bringing it forward into anonymous types
so brief history of
mutation what about current day so let's
talk about some mutation anti patterns
that I have seen things that I have
refined things that have been refactored
or changed or just weird stuff that I've
seen out in the wild that we're where we
know we can fix it by doing other things
right so unnecessary setters is probably
my favorite one because really when I
declare a property I almost always in
most cases if and well if it's a
specific type of case we'll get into why
but most of the time I delete those
setters so I had this particular thing
it's a true story where I had declared
this thing and it had a lot more
properties than this but essentially it
was an interface I column which just
declared that the thing that implemented
it had a column name and a column type
pretty simple nothing really different
or new and this was its implementation
right so it was just a this concrete it
had a concrete implementation with a lot
more stuff in it but this one is the
simplified one just looks like this
again and a not ordered a immutable
structure right I created something not
a structured class technically but I
created something that I didn't want to
mutate because I just wanted to say this
column is a column there's no reason to
have mutation here because they
shouldn't what do they expect they
expect to like change the type of the
column and then like hit save somewhere
right I wanted to avoid that confusion
so we get this columns for table thing
again this is real code where we
numerate the columns for the table
usually by reading the schema table for
the sequel server database or something
right and then we were we'd give it a
table name and then we returned a set of
columns in that table with some metadata
about those columns and suddenly
somebody comes along and says well
really Spencer weird all we're taking
this column this grid column which is
unique identifier in sequel server we're
using another and we're actually moving
the data to another thing so we actually
want this thing to be a string not a
gooood even though the ID is captured is
a gooood we want to capture it a string
we want to call the column type string
because we might declare it down the
road you know we might create a new
table on some other you know data data
sort a data system okay that's fine so
they take this interface that ostensibly
didn't need to be changed and they added
a setter to it
and what they did was they iterated
through each of the columns and they
said if the column type is type of
gooood just change it to a column type
of string an innocuous refactor but I
use that as a teaching moment to teach
the the developer the things of the the
ideals of immutability right because I'm
looking at this code and I'm having now
to reason about it again right I have my
job's hard enough I don't want to think
too much I want to think just enough
right I want to think about interesting
problems so I said there's really no
reason to close that's there to open
that Center because what you're doing is
now intent telling the person who's
consuming that interface that it's okay
to change the value of that data right
that's what you're doing you're giving
them that contract and so what I do is I
told them that projection should be
favored over mutation use link right you
can do something like this where you
just create a set of new columns and you
just say if the column type is a gooood
you just return a string otherwise you
return a column type so favor mutate
projection over mutation where it's
possible and it's practical and you'll
find the more you look at your
collections the more you look at your
code that you will see that that there's
actually lots of opportunities for this
to be for this to be the case and it
goes down to my main principle again my
man Kevin just because you have a getter
doesn't mean you should have a matching
setter right we can leave those guys we
can leave those guys single right they
don't have to be they don't have to be
paired up when I do this and I do and if
if I do this on an interface I better
have a good reason for doing it because
again I'm not trying to I'm trying to
not complicate or make my co-workers
lives harder I'm trying to make them
easier I'm trying to make it so that
they're having to comprehend the code
that I write that I make it as easy on
them as possible because at the end of
the day if you're thinking about open
setters is it open for a reason right
beaten that horse to death we can move
on when I and I and I've really come to
the conclusion that passing mutable data
to methods is really giving that method
permission to change that data as it see
fit and you see this sometimes in these
things that I like to call setup methods
I actually died this is an anti-pattern
that I there's a better name for
somebody please tell me but it's
essentially something like
we contracted with a firm that had a
bunch of junior developers offshore and
we were we're and we were in a sprint
and so you know I was managing another
part of the team and I saw a couple
weeks worth commits my manager approved
them and I saw this where they called
this where they declared something a
repository or some kind of service or
something and then they did this dot and
MIT thing where they're setting up the
state of that data of the data inside of
that object so this Amit method was
really just a method that all it did was
mutate the state of that object in wine
suddenly that suddenly to the chagrin of
any developer who then goes and uses
this repository but doesn't call the
init method this happens boom exceptions
are thrown odd behaviors are had and
then we had to go back and to explain
you know obviously you know there was an
omit method and I had to go back to tell
my manager like you need to stop doing
code reviews and focus on you know
budgets or whatever it is that you're
supposed to do and you know moved on and
so we had them refactor it and it was
all good and the way we have them
refactor it is to provide the factory
pattern now this isn't Java right we
don't want a factory factory bean
factory factory like you some people
have seen those jokes online and it's a
real thing but like a factory wrapping
you know an instance of a service like
that one layer deep that's perfectly
okay so use the factory pattern in that
case it's a good idea to refactor let
that refactor factory pattern do all the
setup that it needs to do instantiate
the object and then return it to the
caller something like that right so in
order to talk about immutability we have
to be pragmatic we are pragmatic
developers by default and we have to
talk about library support because we
have libraries we're not in a mutable
language we're not in a mutable runtime
by default it's not what the it's not
what the runtime coaxes us to it is
c-sharp and VB Z met to default to
mutability so we have to kind of play by
those rules by the data library
developers who have considered that
immutability is a first-class citizen so
the things that we have so this is Anu
this is a I wouldn't say it's relatively
new it's been around for a while now but
a system collections immutable and I do
have a demo
is crazy I know but I really wanted to
kind of show just a little bit about it
so I'm gonna declare what is called an
immutable list and let's zoom that in
make that that doesn't work
got it drag it over here we go that's
better yeah there we go
zoom that in zoom zoom zoom my zoom
thing is not working all right well I'm
gonna copy and paste it then because I
don't really want to let's see yeah that
is not readable so here's what it looks
like got this plus plus plus plus so I'm
gonna run this code by just describing
it we're gonna just describe the
pseudocode make this a little bigger
there we go that looks good all right so
we have here what is the mutable list
and it's got a static method called a
mutable list create give it some strings
you can feed it anywhere from 0 to X
number of strings right and this is an
interesting behavior of this particular
immutable list of this particular
construct when you call list dot add
what it does is it actually creates a
second instance of a mutable array and
appends the objects that you give that
you gave to it and the add method such
that when you get this code when you
when you when you run this code you get
list account of one because that first
one has one element list dot count of
two it has now two elements and then of
course they're different instances right
so they return different instances of
data that's it if you've never seen the
immune I mean everybody's everybody's
probably seen the new get package it's
it's used everywhere by the dotnet team
these days but interesting behavior
right so it's a little bit different
than what we're used to you also have
the list as read-only method which
returns a read-only collection I would
argue that this thing while it is
available is not as powerful or it's
useful as a construct because you can't
you can't you can declare an immutable
list and then add an element to it and
get a second list but you cannot once
you have a read-only list you cannot add
to it the add method from I collection
is that it's actually made private and
the add color the add method on the I
collection interface if you were able to
if you cast it to that and then called
it it would throw and not support an
exception and say you can't do that
so I tend to use immutable lists when I
do use immutable lists so this this this
is my thing
so Auto mapper how many people use
autumn a per oh good amount of you okay
so the good I've got good news you
declare your Auto mapper interface you
declare your Auto mapper you think that
you want to take a person that's in a
beautiful class and you have an employee
that is a like maybe an entity framework
class more on that later and you want to
create a map from that employee to that
person and you do so and then you call
map or dot does it blow up does it call
the constructor it calls the constructor
it will do it will do matching by
convention which is what Auto mapper
already does for us so it'll take this
first and last name and here and try its
best to match them to the first-name and
lastname parameters on the auto mapper
on the on the on the target mat the
target object that's being mapped to
Auto mapper has that behavior by default
I mean if it doesn't you can always use
the constructor use it you can always
declare your map with the construct
using and then you know actually provide
it a specific constructor to use which
is pretty useful Newton's soft ed Jason
again the same thing what have we what
are we going to get when we do serialize
this person object into our person class
first name last name good news is that
Newton soft Jason does the exact same
thing it does it will take those things
it will map them by convention and we'll
put try to match them to the properties
on your constructor if it can't find a
valid constructor then it will throw an
exception so your contracts have to be
really tight you know you can't just
send I don't say I don't think it works
I've never tried it actually but if you
sent if you needed an extra variable
inside of your constructor and you
didn't pass it into your Jason body I
think you get an exception if you have
multiple constructors the only
limitation is you have to choose one and
you choose one by annotating it with the
Jason constructor constructor attribute
so I think it's worth mentioning system
text Jason how many people are already
on dotnet score three yeah so how many
people have you have looked much into
the system text JSON API few of you how
many people have tried to use system
text
like Newton soft and gotten prot and had
problems yeah a few of you my aunt
raised two I had the same thing so I dug
into the behavior I actually have a
youtube video I that you could it I did
a blog post you can find the link to my
website on my Twitter profile I I did a
YouTube video explaining some of the
differences between system text Jason
and Newton sock Jason system text Jason
is just a completely different animal
and it will it will not unlike Newton
soft Jason it will not deceive it will
not just serialize immutable classes by
default you have to actually declare a
json converter a specific one specific
to that class is at the end of the world
no not necessarily
is it kind of annoying maybe it depends
I think it depends on your design goals
I think for for most people that are
making that aren't you know having to
need that high performance that system
text Jason gives you sticking with
Newton soft Jason is just fine so word
to the wise it's not apples to apples
not even close
here's another pattern that I use that I
find to be useful especially when I'm
deep when I am creating kind of
framework like libraries for other
developers to consume which is the
Builder pattern so take an object that's
meant to build upon an object how many
people use auto FAQ lots of I think a
lot of auto facts mine my di container
of choice and I think other ones do the
same thing where you have a container
builder you register all your services
then you call container dot the Builder
build or whatever the case may be and
then you get an instance of your actual
auto FAQ service resolver and that's the
Builder pattern in effect if you've ever
done something like add dbcontext inside
of a dotnet or an asp net court
application you probably saw this class
at some point which is like they I
boiled it down to just a couple of
properties right but the DV context
options builder which provides open
setters for properties that you can set
and what I see a lot is they will say
use DB context and behind the scenes
this options builder allows you to set
the things inside the the configuration
options inside of you
or options builder and at the end the
use dbcontext wraps over that it calls
builder build and now you have an
immutable config object so now you can't
change the connection string of your DB
can't be context options in the middle
of the runtime you can't change it now
again you get this right you get this
dbcontext options look ma no open
setters and obviously a for brevity I
eliminated all the other constructor
stuff but you get the idea the parent
object is the Builder it produces child
objects that are immutable
useful so I think it's important to talk
about the kind of the yin and the yang
with the good and with the good comes
the bad and the bitter comes the sweet
and the bottom line is that mutability
and functional ideas only work go so far
in c-sharp because c-sharp Wilko kicking
and screaming in certain ways it's just
not a language that's designed to be
functional up front and that's okay
right
c-sharp is really good at doing the
things that c-sharp is good at but in
some ways
mutability is a mutability as a
requirement for different things and it
can feel it is immutability on objects
by default is required for different
libraries and it can feel sometimes like
you're putting lipstick on a pig because
you're really trying like anybody who
dogmatically says in c-sharp if you're
an architect if you're the lead
developer and you say we are closing all
setters all setters are closing we're
never mutating data again that sounds
like a Haskell program or like not
pragmatic right it just can't do that
it's you can do that but you're gonna
have a lot of struggles along the way
and you do have to evaluate the
trade-offs end of the framework is a
great example of a library that just is
just malign mutability at it's very core
right and that makes sense that kind of
makes sense because entity framework is
a abstraction over usually a sequel
database where we have rows and in those
roads we have columns and those columns
the data can change we just update the
data if that's the permanent data store
that's the data is resting place and we
move on with our lives
so entity framework with those
principles with those principles in mind
and c-sharp with it
every entity class that I declare has an
open center because it's pragmatic it
does what entity framework wants you to
do you cannot get around that fact oh
I'm sorry you can get around that fact
here's what it looks like so you can
declare a class that has a constructor
that the real people use that's the non
machine folks that develop and you can
declare it with a parameter list
constructor that enemy framework can use
but oh wait we got a market with
obsolete and we got to make sure it's
true
mob silly comment with the message comma
true so that way it gives a compiler
error when you compile it and then you
have to declare you have to declare an
ID with an open Center anyways because
entity framework and then you have to
declare your properties as getters over
fields and then you can go to the stack
overflow this is the except I don't
remember if this is the accepted answer
or not I swear - I hope it's not because
now you can also do this right where you
have to we you also have to do this
where you actually have to tell the DB
context as you're creating your model as
you're creating the entities that are
that you're creating these entities and
creating a representation of these
entities you're having to go through and
actually tell it for each of these
properties you actually have to set
property access mode field which I can
guess as to what that does but like I
feels like this like that code just
feels like all you're doing is taking
steps and you're hitting ranks right
you're just dislikes or slamming in your
face you're not adding value in my
opinion and that gets back to the
balancing act question because I am
never ever just because I like
mutability and use it pragmatically in
my C sharp application does not mean
that I am going to enforce it throughout
my developers would want to kill me my
boss would tell me no right it's just
not it's not practical it's not pretty
it's not always practical another good
example or a messaging framework our
messaging frameworks that depending on
the serializer that you create like and
service bus is one that we use and its
default serializer cannot handle
immutable objects so what am I supposed
to do I can either use the JSON
serialize or which I do sometimes or I
can just treat it like a mutable object
this treat it like an immutable object
don't like but don't mutate it right
just enforce that and use code reviews
and process to kind of enforce that
because at the end of the day it's a
bigger struggle for end service bus and
it's more code and it's more headache
than we want there is a trade-off right
there is a trade-off not only in terms
of comprehension for your employees for
the developers that you work with
there's also a cost right and you have
to establish whether or not that cost is
worth the benefits in many cases it is
I declare mutable immutable services all
the time I declare mutable data
structures all the time usually what I
do is if I'm passing them to other
methods I might take them instead of if
I'm using entity framework with it I
might use Auto mapper and couple it with
project two or something like that in
order to then hydrate that model if I
even want to hydrate that immutable
model if I even want to go that far most
of the time I defer to using immutable
models inside of highly critical parts
of our system where I don't want the
developers that come in and refactor
that to break things by just saying
mutate mutate data in in this particular
place to get this one shortcut oh I had
this oh we had the the the team that we
were working with did this horrible
thing once where they were we were using
CQRS and we were passing a message off
to a request handler and they were
passing it that so it was going through
a validator through a request handler
and they didn't know what they were they
didn't know how to just kind of keep
things pure and keep make sure that
there wasn't a bunch of spaghetti code
so what they did was they added to the
message object they added a list of
error messages to the error out to the
messaging object the object that's
supposed to describe our intent not the
response object and they started
appending messages to it and you know
what the code is backed by unit tests
and I never refactored it because I just
didn't feel like it it was one of those
things but at the end of the day I was
like the the intent of this has been
lost right you've made this code way
more confusing by not defining a clean
separation between your request your
validator your Handler and your response
right that should go on a response
object it should be some kind of Builder
pattern behind the scenes establishing
that well I guess it's American currency
so I guess this is probably more Pro
Britt and probably after tonight this is
more appropriate so talking about our
main takeaway so what has again what has
a immutability meant to me as a
developer so the mutability has really
kind of helped me evaluate at a higher
level right it's not just about like
closing setters and just being done at a
higher level it's helped me evaluate the
state of my application when I started
embracing and sprinkling immutability
pragmatically throughout my codebase I
started to kind of consider how I'd been
programming in the past and once I
learned those functional concepts once I
learn those functional ideals as it were
I started looking at my code more
critically it made me think about my
code differently and it helped make me a
more defensive programmer so checking
for null checking for empty string right
making sure that my validators are not
only in place for my web requests for
example but not not only just making
sure that they are well that they're
well validating that object but that
tests are really good at backing that
object so really defensively programming
it's really just helped me change my
mindset more when programming
defensively can include making things
that are immutable optimum and making
immutable objects right because if you
know that the state can't change you can
make a lot of other assumptions about it
like that well you can make that the
object that is passed from one method
down to a hundred other methods will
never change and that's a very powerful
assumption how many people have worked
in web forms yeah how many people still
work in web forms no how many people
don't want to admit it
so in web forms I inherited an
application where that was the default
behavior where we would just pass these
things we would pass an object that was
represented like an active record sort
so to speak and it was just passed
method to method to method and sometimes
mutated along the way sometimes not and
I'm not calling out this isn't a web
forms problem this was a problem kind of
born of just the attitude of the time
where web forms when web forms was
popular that was sort of a thing you did
I'm saying that we can do better that's
pretty much all I'm saying is so I look
for those opportunities to make sure
that I close those setters and make sure
that methods aren't mutating data at the
very least so mutate sparingly use it
use it where it makes sense right use it
in your message
or message fairy messaging frameworks
where immutability the cost of
immutability it's just like you're
having to add on or worker add-in
workarounds to make things work fast or
better or make it work with the library
you're trying to shoehorn it in you
don't have to do that right you don't
have to do that in any framework - you
can't do it at any framework I would
argue that it makes your code it's
actually a net negative right it makes
your code harder to read
so mutate sparingly but pragmatically
right aligned with your team and I think
this is a really important one I think
that Inlet if your team is not on board
with the idea of immutability if you're
if you're if you go back to your team
and you say you know we we ought to
start you know we ought to start taking
a critical look at our application and
thinking about places where immutability
can't change if nine out of ten of your
co-workers say you know what this isn't
our problem I don't care to learn this I
don't care to do things differently I'll
actually you have a different problem
but at the bottom line is is if you try
to chew horn immutability as a mindset
inside of your application inside of
your co-workers and your and your team
in general and it's not working then
that's just one of those things that you
just kind of have to give up your team
has to be in alignment and that's
generally speaking true for most
technology adoption and I'm telling you
that if you shoot horn immutability into
dotnet and sacrifice readability or
maintaining you're not making you're not
solving a problem you're just
transferring a problem somewhere else
more more importantly immutable thinking
has really gotten me thinking about the
applications that I create not just the
C sharp and dotnet that I write but the
architecture of those applications so
for example the Twitter example was a
perfect it was was is a perfect way of
expressing that right because we didn't
have to worry about tweets having to be
edited or changed anyway except for
retweets and lights which are additive
right they we aren't we are able to
simplify our architecture by not making
edits a first-class citizen and it's
aren't a thing you can only delete make
the tweet disappear otherwise you can't
do anything with it we didn't have to
think about all of those different parts
of our architecture imagine if Twitter
decided to add an edit button and what
they did was when you retweeted a tweet
the person who retweeted that tweet that
original copies
but then when they edited the tweet it
stayed the same now you're having just
take that tweet and spread it amongst
you know save it to a hundred different
databases for a hundred different people
who retweeted it who knows the problems
are endless the problems get complicated
so mutable thinking has really kind of
blown my mind in a way it just caused me
to think about the applications that I
build a little differently persistent
data structures are a great example
persistent data structure is something
is a data structure that saves a copy of
itself when it is changed so what you
have essentially is a log kind of a of
all of the changes that were made to
that object immutable list is a great
example of one that is a first-class net
citizen is a it is a library that is
written by the dotnet team too that
embraces the idea of a persistent data
structure well then I didn't want to
mention event sourcing but I think it's
worth mentioning because event sourcing
really kind of takes that ideal to the
extreme the problem with the event
sourcing is as many people miss apply it
and that's another problem but that idea
for example could have saved a situation
several years ago at a company that I
worked for where suddenly we over wrote
all sorts of customer data and we
figured out why but recovering from that
was incredibly difficult because we had
mutated the data in place and not kept a
history of the data mutation in this
case it was accounting software and we
were we were overwriting their vendors
and their customers and you can imagine
their accountants probably wanted to
kill us
Countians like don't don't like you
messing with your system
things like Redux how many people are
front-end developers in any way shape or
form okay a few of you so Redux is a
state management application inside of
inside it for react and it is it lives
on the front end so it's written in
JavaScript so it stores it is an opinion
about how data is stored and one of the
things that it does is it doesn't mutate
state directly it actually creates a new
copy of state which enables some useful
behaviors like a time travel debugging
because you're able to see the chain
this changes in state if you having to
debug you can literally go back in time
to a point at which that before a
certain mutation took place you're able
to
go back and see that you're also able to
possibly persist that data if you wanted
to and enable functions like undo redo
like how easy would it be if you had a
copy of the previous state and you hit
the undo button and you just replace the
current state with the previous state
right you've not mutated in place you're
not taking tracks of mutation you're
taking copies of entire objects so it
becomes really simple to do and so in
that way it's really expanded my mind in
terms of the in terms of how I think
about systems and how I think about
building systems and architecture in
general and at the end of the day if I
can change your mind about immutability
might just be able to change the world
she's the ending to thank you very much
I appreciate all you being here I've
really got through that really quickly
but yeah well it's just the way it goes
does anybody have any questions yes the
question is let me make sure I summed it
up correctly was that was that you had a
method that took in an ienumerable and
the question was like how do you know
that that ienumerable won't be changed
by another thread why wouldn't you make
it in a new mutable list in that case or
something like that
the answer is is I thought that
something was accessed by could be
accessed by multiple threads and I
thought if I thought that at all I would
defer to using an immutable array or an
immutable list or something like that I
wouldn't I'd probably go a mutable array
if I didn't expect those operations to
be exposed because meetable array
doesn't expose adds and removes to
create different lists so I would
I would I would certainly choose to use
an immutable array so that way that
guarantee is in place if the data is to
change then then I want to make sure
that you know if I'm in numerating that
ienumerable suddenly I get invalid
operation exception anyway so you want
to protect against that but that's
really a question of like that's a
bigger question of like what did you
write and how did you design what was
the design of the thing that you wrote I
got you
I would I mean in that case like that
sounds kind of like a data reader to me
but like I mean it to some degree are
you is it forward only because you
didn't want to like persistent in memory
or something like that or you didn't
want to persist into memory necessarily
or was it already a data structure that
was in memory
well I mean your question of like a
forward only reader that's also
immutable to me that's a perfect use of
like an iterator or something which uses
you know the wheeled keyword inside of
an enumerable or if you're talking about
async operations async enumerable which
was just released in c-sharp eight huh
if anybody doesn't isn't familiar with
async enumerable go to my website I have
a blog post on it and why it's useful
and why it's important but your your
question is like as it's reading from
the database I assume that if it's in
the middle of reading it and somebody
adds an item to that that database like
that item isn't going to be returned but
in the middle of a query so most of them
most of the time I think you're talking
about kind of it's a little bit sounds
like a little bit of an edge KC problem
but good question you know the bottom
line is if you think that the data could
mutate by and be mutated by another
thread and you want to protect against
that immutable immutable collections are
the way to go and there's any other
questions good question
are we just ready to get out here in
party all right well listen my twitter
handle is at Schneider Bach if you have
any other questions for me the
conversation doesn't end because we
leave here today hit me up on Twitter DM
me email me whatever I have lots of
contact information on my website but
thank you very much for coming to NDC
London I hope you had an amazing time
and I hope to see you back here in 2021
thank you very much
you